In the quiz, we analyze the stability of the forward Euler method.
Now, we introduce some changes to turn the forward Euler method to backward Euler method.
This method is called an implicit solver. We are going to see why.
The backward Euler method works like this to go from the initial value of x
to the value after the first step, it added the step size times the rate of change at times 0.
The backward Euler method works with the rate of change at the end of the first step, x(h).
Actually, our estimate of the rate of change at the end of the first step.
Keep in mind that I'm writing x(h) but I'm referring to my estimates,
the numerical solution of the exact solution.
This means that the value at the end of the first step appears
on the left-hand side and on the right-hand side.
This is why this is called an implicit method, we have to solve for x(h).
It's hidden in this equation. It's not explicit so let's solve for x(h).
When this term over to the left-hand side, then we have x at the end of the first step
plus time step times constant times x at the end of the first step equals the initial value,
we can factor out x(h) and find that x(h) equals the initial value divided by 1+hk.
This is something like 1/1+100 if you choose a really large h which would be 1/101.
If you form powers of these, they are going to decay pretty quickly
and there is no oscillation whatsoever, so we have no problem at all with this expression.
It's always going to work no matter how large the steps as is.
This is very handy when one tries to solve stiff differential equations.